tu avais tout
nous sommes entre 24 tous les grands
studios sont venus ramper et tu as claqué
toutes les portes ouvertes écrasé tous les
rêves Aaron a besoin de moi à la maison qu'Aaron
n'est qu'une excuse oh maintenant qu'est-ce qu'ils
proposent nous voulons tous vous scanner  de vous
votre corps votre visage les mouvements que vous
riez ou larmes que vous voulez échantillonner vous
vous préservez quand vous voulez posséder cette
chose appelée Robin juste une fois que je
vous échantillonne et que vous êtes dans votre ordinateur il n'y a aucun
moyen de revenir en arrière le studio possède le personnage
ou le personnage le  celui qui était l'
acteur je veux te faire réveiller pour toujours
robin c'est ton rendez-vous avec la liberté
sourire puis-je retourner d'où je viens
il n'y a rien de tel c'est l'endroit d'
où tu viens
wow tu es fantastique
le sixième  miss six Robyn,
comment puis-je savoir si je rêve regarde
pour trouver Aaron c'est ce qu'on appelle un très long
voyage
tu fais juste un choix et tu ressens
ce que tu veux
tu choisis